let's stick with covet a little bit uh
on Fox News
right after praising coveted vaccines
Greg Gutfeld very casually segues into
covid was created by scientists just
without even any hesitation without any
even raising of an eyebrow Gutfeld says
that and of course we have no evidence
for that that's one of the early
conspiracy theories that surged about
covid take a look at this bizarre clip
on Fox News as sick as people were so I
think that's that's the thing that we
can still have these conversations but
the president's largely right and anyone
on his team who doesn't believe it maybe
they should look for other work okay
wrap it up correct well I got to go with
Harold on this I think that if we sit we
cannot have it both ways we can't hail
operation warp speed and then laugh
about
the vaccines vaccines may not prevent
coven but they certainly reduce the
severity of it that's what it's there
for but the thing that drives me crazy
is that we still we have to accept that
more than likely it was man-made why why
why would we have to accept that and
when you think about it it's now the
third part of the cold and flu season I
don't think it's ever going to go away I
think you can have cold flu and covid
it's like our siblings in sickness got a
new little brother like cold in the okay
so he's reading that this is I guess
comedy gutfeld's a comedian so he's
reading some of this stuff off of his
notes which is fine but none of it's
funny and it's also not true so this has
been studied always remember
when a conspiracy theory has attached to
it Like A Parasite and they won't even
let us investigate
Bing that should set your alarms up is
that true is that true that we can't
even investigate the so-called lab leak
hypothesis has been investigated
extensively and there are two versions
of the lab leak hypothesis one the most
weaponized is covid was deliberately
created as a bio weapon and released to
kill people
that's one hypothesis the slightly less
cuckoo hypothesis is it was being
studied and it accidentally escaped the
lab because someone at the lab infected
themselves and then left and then it
spread from there those are the two kind
of layers now the view of scientists is
that both of those are very unlikely
right now the most likely scenario and
again in science we talk in terms of
probabilities the most likely scenario
is What's called the natural zoonotic
jump from animals to humans the entire
idea of lab leak
is based initially on
Wuhan
markets is where we were told it came
from
and there's a virology lab in Wuhan so
it's very easy to claim it was from the
markets when it was really from the lab
because they're both physically in
proximity that's the bulk of why people
are talking about this now the truth is
there's lots of these types of labs in
many places
um and that should also kind of make us
question whether that makes sense now is
it possible that this was being studied
in that particular lab and someone was
accidentally infected and then they left
and then they started spreading it to
other people and that's how it entered
the human population it is of course
possible but we have been told no one at
that lab was sick at the time covid
emerged but could they be lying there
are claims that that's a lie well you
look at the clusters of early covid
cases and you see that there are links
to multiple markets in Wuhan around the
exact same time and so that supports the
idea that some animals Animal Traders
brought the virus in in animals to the
city brought those animals to a bunch of
the markets in Wuhan sold in many
markets and spread from there now you
know we could go further on this
at this point it's completely
irresponsible to say we have to admit
the most likely scenario is that this
was created by scientists that is not
the most likely scenario based on what
we know today if that changes I will be
the first to tell you